اسرائيل يدركونها بان امريكا تشارك في
المناورات العسكريه وتحاكي قصف منشاه
نوويه تحت الرمال صحراء النقب لكنها لا
تريد المشاركه في هجوم فعلي على منشات
ايران النوويه وهو متروك لاسرائيل وحدها
ومعضلتها ان الضربه العسكريه المستقله
ليست جاهزه بعد وايران باتت على عتبه
القدره النوويه العسكريه وما يفصلها عن
القنبله النوويه هو قرارها وليس عائقا
بقليا الماسه لا يوجد ولاده اسرائيل
على تقدم المشروع النووي وذلك بسبب انشغل
الاسره الدوليه وعلى راسه الولايات
المتحده بقضايا اخرى جزء من الضجيج
الاعلامي الذي اثاره الامريكيون تحديدا
يرمي الى رضعه ايران ومنع انطلاقها الى
تقسيم اليورانيوم بنسبه 90% وهو ما تخشى
اسرائيل ان يتم وتضطر الى شنه هجوم منه
غير جاهز وغير مضمون النتائج
هذه المناورات الاوسع نطاق بين اللجين
الاسرائيلي والامريكي وهو النموذج الثالث
الذي يتدرب فيه الجيش ويحاكي استهداف
المنشات النوويه في ايران رساله مشتركه
بمشاركه مقاتلات وقذفات امريكيه
استراتيجيه اسرائيل تبقى رفض العوده
للانتفاق النووي مع ايران او التوصل
لاتفاق شامل ومغير ووضع خيار عسكري امريكي
مصداقيه على طاوله وتخشى ان لم تغير
واشنطن اداءها ان تفاجئ ايران يوما
بامتلاك سلاح النووي كما فعلت كوريا
الشماليه من قبل زياد حلبي العربيه القدس
الغربيه